le vent est à l'est la brume se lève
quelque chose se prépare et arrivera tôt
mesdames et messieurs nous commençons
notre descente vers le sans gêne je vous
présente la créatrice de notre bien-aimé
mary poppins jamais se contenter de
marée et où se trouve monsieur disney
vous voilà voilà bien comment ce faux
prix venait il a énormément d'idées quel
genre d'idée responsable responsable
ce mot n'existe pas on l'a inventée
ensemble et bien désinventer le la
maison dépens que c'est pas du tout
comme ça tout est à revoir tout et part
en moi j'ai décidé d'arrêter je ne vous
laisserai pas en faire un deux roues
stupide dès samedi la femme qui envoie
une nounou volante au parapluie parlant
sauver des enfants
vous croyez que mary poppins est venu
sauver les enfants juste ciel
madame travers ce qu'est ce qui m'a
échappé
mary poppins et les boks sont comme ma
famille mary poppins a réellement existé
alors ce ne sont pas les enfants que les
venait sauver c'est le repère c'est
votre père vous ne savez pas ce qu'elle
représente pour moi vous ne serez pas
déçus
n'avez vous pas envie d'écrire la fin de
l'histoire
[Musique]